president Trump referred to the
impeachment inquiry against him as a
lynching and the left is absolutely
furious that the man that they have
spent three years calling and Nazi would
even consider referencing racial
violence in his metaphor we will use our
high-tech to examine the history of
high-tech lynchings then a major win and
an even worse setback for sanity in the
gender identity movement a possible new
Democratic presidential candidate and
assurance from Miley Cyrus that you
don't have to be gay and even more weird
creepy Democrat sex scandals all that
and more I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what a day what a day we're gonna be
talking about lynchings gender identity
whether or not you have to be gay Miley
Cyrus is words not mine
and Democrat sex scandals but first I've
got to thank our friends over at Mint
mobile you know I know you sign up for a
big wireless plan you don't really know
what you're getting but you sign on the
line and then every month you don't know
what they're gonna charge you all you
know is they're gonna charge you a lot
more than you thought you were signing
up for
that is where mint mobile comes in mint
mobile can cut your cell phone bill down
to 15 bucks a month
Oh Michael that's not possible there's
no way it's gonna be 15 plus this plus
that no 15 bucks a month that's it how
does it work the way it works is that
big cell companies sell you unlimited
data that you don't need you're on Wi-Fi
for the vast majority of your day
whether it's at home or at the office or
wherever you're not using it so what you
can do with a mint mobile plan you can
get unlimited nationwide talking text
you can get extremely fast 4G LTE data
you can cut that bill down to 15 bucks a
month with your existing phone number
with your existing contacts you can use
your own phone with any mint mobile plan
if you're not 100% satisfied with mint
mobile they've got you covered with the
seven day money-back guarantee but you
are going to love it I know I know
you've been burned so much that you
don't believe that you can get yourself
owned bill down to 15 bucks a month you
truly can to get your new wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to mint
mobile.com slash Knolls that's mint
mobile comm slashing holes can Oh W le s
cuts your wireless bill down to 15 bucks
a month
mint mobile.com slash Knolls here it is
here is lynch gate President Trump used
the word lynching in a metaphor to refer
to a political attack against him he
tweeted out quote so someday if a
Democrat becomes president and the
Republicans win the White House even by
a tiny margin they can impeach the
president without due process or
fairness or any legal rights all
presidents all Republicans must remember
what they are witnessing here a lynching
but we will win
okay I've heard this before you might
think you've heard this before but the
Democrats the left are furious the
president Trump would ever reference
racial violence in his metaphor for
comment we turn now to beta our work is
that act only too far to make a
comparison between the President of the
United States and the Nazis find me a
better analogy of another leader of a
Western democracy describing all people
of one religion as inherently defective
or disqualified or dangerous and that's
what president has done when it comes to
Muslims seeking to ban all Muslims from
this country
repeating the lie that Mexican
immigrants posed a risk to this country
calling them animals and predators and
rapists and criminals asking for women
of color elected by their constituents
to Congress to go back to their home
country and having a an almost Nuremberg
like rally where people are chanting
send her back oh it's okay when the left
does it but it's not okay when Trump
does it by the way he opens up and he
calls Trump a Nazi then he lists all
these things that Trump didn't do he
never said that all people who were
Muslims are terrible awful people he
never said that all people who were
Mexicans are rapists and murderers never
did any of those things then it ends
with Nuremberg so he brings it back to
Nuremberg in the end that's okay but
when President Trump uses the word
lynching that is evil the left was
actually trying to to defend this
distinction yesterday they were actually
trying you would see it all over the
internet they were saying look Trump is
doing things like the Nazis and
therefore it's okay to invoke racial
violence against Jews in the 1930s and
40s when you're talking about a metaphor
with Trump but it's not okay to invoke
lynchings that was actually the position
that they were trying to defend with a
straight face until we used our little
high technology over here to go into the
way Wayback Machine of the Internet
which is forever to find out that the
Democrats have actually used the word
lynching in political metaphors for a
very very long time so here's here's the
left you're the Democrats with a real
straight face telling you how absolutely
terrible it is to use the word lynching
how dare
the president compared lynching to
impeachment oh yeah I don't know how to
characterize that from our president
except as grotesque thousands of
african-americans were slaughtered
during the lynching epidemic in this
country for no reason other than the
color of their skin how dare he do this
does he not know the history of lynching
in this country the president should not
compare a constitutionally mandated
impeachment inquiry to such a dangerous
and dark chapter of American history
it's irresponsible for him to do so and
I hope that he will apologize does he
not know that thousands of African
Americans were lynched mob violence does
he not know that this is the equivalent
of murder how dare the president compare
article 2 section 4 of the Constitution
a lawful constitutional process to mob
violence and lynching it makes you no
better than those who burn crosses it
makes you no better than those who wear
hoods and white robes do you not
understand what you're doing to this
country that's right if you use the word
lynching in a political metaphor you are
basically a member of the Ku Klux Klan
you're basically committing racially
motivated lynchings yourself Joe Biden
tweets out impeachment is not lynching
it is part of our Constitution our
country is a dark shameful history with
lynching and even think to even think
about making this comparison is
abhorrent it's despicable
isn't that right Joe Biden isn't that
right Democrats it's abhorrent right you
would never ever do it right Joe Biden
the president should be impeached
history is going to question whether or
not this was just a partisan lynching
or whether or not it was something that
in fact met the standard the very high
bar that was set by the founders as to
what constituted an impeachable offense
and indeed it is a political lynching
political lynch mob I will not vote for
this lynching we're in so much hurry to
get this done so it can be in the
Saturday Sunday news cycle and have our
mint juleps at 5 o'clock we are gonna
find a rope find a tree and ask a bunch
of questions no that's far Biden
obviously didn't expect this to come out
so he responded to this on Twitter
because they said wait a second dude you
you did the same thing you went when it
was the impeachment of Bill Clinton you
were all using the same exact language
that Trump used that you're is a liam 4
and Biden tweets this out quote this
wasn't the right word to use and I'm
sorry about that
Trump on the other hand chose his words
deliberately today in his use of the
word lynching and continues to stoke
racial divides in this country daily he
Joe Biden actually said yeah when I said
it it was fine but when Trump said it
it's really really bad because he didn't
remember that he said this that he used
that and by the way it's not like they
just used the word once they all used it
a lot and then by the end you had Jim
McDermott they're saying we're gonna go
get a rope he's actually vividly
describing this now of course all of
this the Democrats and president Trump's
reference was brought along by a the
most famous use of this metaphor which
was by Justice Clarence Thomas when
leftists tried to railroad his
nomination to the Supreme Court Clarence
Thomas famously said this is a circus
it's a national disgrace
it's a high-tech lynching for uppity
blacks something is dreadfully wrong
with this country
when any person any person in this free
country would be subjected to this this
is not a closed room there was an FBI
investigation this is not an opportunity
to talk about difficult
matters privately or in a closed
environment this is a circus it's a
national disgrace and from my standpoint
as a black American as far as I'm
concerned it is a high-tech lynching for
uppity blacks who in any way deign to
think for themselves to do for
themselves to have different ideas and
it is a message that unless you count to
an old order this is what will happen to
you you will be lynched destroyed
caricatured by a committee of the u.s.
US Senate rather than hung from a tree
incredibly powerful testimony from
Clarence Thomas it ended the whole
ridiculous circus of them trying to
railroad his Supreme Court nomination
they've been they've been doing it too
conservative nominees ever since Judge
Bork in the 1980s and obviously they
still do it up to Brett Kavanaugh and so
Clarence Thomas uses this famous phrase
high-tech lynching the phrase has a long
history in political metaphors because
it serves as a good metaphor what's so
amazing though it's not just that we've
forgotten the history of the term
lynching in politics we've actually
forgotten the history of lynching and
it's all part and parcel of this leftist
constant strategy to silence
conservatives to say that they can say
certain things they can do whatever they
want they can speak their mind but when
conservatives speak their mind it's evil
and terrible and they have to get shut
up we'll get into the real history of
that in a second then we'll get into the
high-tech lynching itself we'll get into
impeachment possible new Democratic
candidate for president and weird weird
leftist sex scandals but first I've got
to thank our friends over at NetSuite
I've been a part of a number of growing
businesses businesses that I've helped
to start businesses I was there at the
very beginning and one of the biggest
problems that always happens with
growing businesses is they have these
different systems to manage different
aspects so you've got you're managing
your numbers over here your accounting
your HR your all these different
computer systems they're not talking to
one another introducing NetSuite by
Oracle
which is the business management
software that handles every aspect of
your business
in an easy-to-use cloud platform so
really importantly gives you visibility
and control that you need to grow so
with NetSuite you can save time and
money and unneeded headaches and what
people forget is that time is money and
those unneeded headaches are cost you
both time and money it manages sales
finance and accounting orders HR
instantly right from your desktop or
your phone that is why NetSuite is the
world's number one cloud business system
when you're growing your business there
are enough challenges do not make it
hard on yourself unnecessarily use the
best system give yourself visibility
save time and money get an advantage in
your business right now NetSuite is
offering you valuable insights with a
free guide that guy to seven key
strategies to grow your profits at
NetSuite dot-com / Knowles canna wles
that's totally free and really really
excellent advice to get you started
NetSuite dot-com / Knowles canna wles to
download your FREE guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits NetSuite
comm / Knowles so what's the history of
lynching is it okay to use lynching is
it only okay for Democrats to use
lynching is it only okay for leftists
choose the word lynching obviously the
term lynching has a racial component to
it so from from 1882 to 1964 there were
forty seven hundred forty-three
lynchings recorded in the United States
that's a lot of lynchings I mean you're
talking about a period of 90 years or
something during an incredibly racially
divided period and so you know you could
think the number would be a would be
significantly higher than that but still
forty seven hundred forty three
lynchings recorded in the United States
seventy two point seven percent of those
were perpetrated against black people
also a sort of surprising number because
at least in my mind before I knew that
historical tidbit I thought 100 percent
were perpetrated against black people
but that actually wasn't the case it was
the vast majority of them but not all
little less than three quarters an
additional twenty seven point three
percent were not perpetrated against
black people they were perpetrated
against other people actually it turns
out little-known historical tidbit the
largest mass lynching in the history of
the United States we
against Italians it was a group of 11
Italian Americans in New Orleans they
were all lynched on mass in 1891 and
that's part of the reason why the next
year in 1892 we started to celebrate
Columbus Day before leftists ruined that
holiday too
the term Lynch itself also does not
reference killings of black people
that's not where the term Lynch comes
from so what Edda model adjusts believe
etymologists people who are studying the
meaning and history of words they
believe that phrase arose during the
American Revolution and it referred to
Lynch's law specifically to these two
brothers Charles and William Lynch and
what Lynch meant specifically was not
even just you know hanging somebody you
know in the mob violence it was all
extrajudicial punishments of punishments
that took place outside the scope of
proper jurisdiction and the law Charles
Lynch was a guy who headed a County
Court and during the American Revolution
he imprisoned Tory's people who were
sympathetic to the British for up to a
year even though he didn't have proper
jurisdiction so he basically took
justice into his own hands and imprison
these Tories during the American
Revolution but it's not like he was this
was being used against black people
specifically we just had the term later
came to be used actually Charles Lynch
does appear to have had a racial bias
but the racial bias was not against
black people yeah he acquitted black
people of murder on at least three
occasions the racial bias
it would appear was actually against
Welsh miners he just had a real thing
for the Welsh so that's the early
history of the term then there's the
question that the left is posing which
is is there a racial requirement to use
plain language more or less what they're
saying is Trump can't use the word Lynch
because he's not a black person and it
turns out that the white Democrats were
all using that word Lynch they say well
yeah they they can use it too because
they because we give them permission to
use that but no but white Republicans
are not allowed to use that obviously
you do not need to pass some racial
purity test to use a metaphor that is
not the case but if there is a racial
purity test to use a metaphor
allow me certainly
my Sicilian heritage should give me some
say in this stupid leftist premise given
that Italians were the victims of the
largest mass lynching in American
history
so I hereby invoke my southern Italian
DNA to officially absolve president
Trump of the sin of using a metaphor is
the metaphor apt abso lutely what are
what is a metaphor a metaphor is when
you're comparing something to something
else so if you you go out you say hey
how how'd you how'd you do on that test
on that exam you say I killed it is that
offensive to victims of murder and the
family of victims of murder no it's not
you're using a metaphor you didn't
actually murder the exam but you can
have you killed it man you Slade you did
a great job right same thing with the
word lynching it's why it's being used
by people of all races of all parties to
refer to political acts and hear what
the president is talking about is he's
saying there is an extrajudicial illegal
process going on to remove me from
office because the Democrats are upset
they lost the 2016 election that is
happening that's been happening for
three years there is no legal basis for
this impeachment inquiry right now how
do I know that because they've been
trying to impeach him since day one and
they've been looking for a crime it's an
impeachment in search of an impeachable
offense first it was Russia then it was
stormy Daniels now it's a long-distance
phone call to Ukraine basically how else
do I know that this is extrajudicial the
impeachment inquiry is completely shut
Republicans out this is not one branch
of government doing its duly appointed
oversight duties on another branch of
government
this is left-wing Democrats shutting out
members of their own branch of
government to try to attack the
president who's of the opposite party
how else do I know this so much of this
is based on anonymous whistleblowers
who's the so-called whistleblower we
have no idea
we have no idea that's that obviously
the Democrats haven't thought far enough
ahead about this because if they
actually do impeach the president and
it's gonna go to trial in the Senate and
if it goes to trial in the Senate
Lindsey Graham is definitely gonna call
that whistleblower to testify so this
this isn't gonna last forever I don't
think the Democrats even think we're
care that it's going to get that
or this is a political stunt being used
to affect the 2020 election and very
likely to anticipate the IG
investigation and the durum
investigation which are looking into all
the Democrat misdeeds that occurred in
the 2016 election and they're basically
trying to get out ahead of that and say
that everybody's corrupt but on the
extra-judicial part on the illegal
aspect of us let's not forget how many
sources in this impeachment push have
been anonymous they've been murky
they've been hiding in the shadows of
the bureaucracy you can't face your
accuser you can't answer these charges
just the other day to use an example of
this that is slightly related Chris
Wallace even on Fox News came out and he
said you know big-time Republicans tell
me there's a good chance that Trump gets
thrown out of office but he doesn't say
who the big-time Republican is it's an
anonymous source much worse than that
the New York Times published an
anonymous op-ed last year called quote I
am part of the resistance inside the
Trump administration published
anonymously so breaking with precedent
and with norms of journalism and the
sub-header was I work for the president
but like-minded colleagues and I have
vowed to thwart parts of his agenda and
his worst inclinations basically saying
I am part of the swamp and I am gonna
undermine the election of 2016 I'm gonna
undermine the duly elected president
because I want to and no one can stop me
and this is being abetted by the
mainstream news media and by the left
but I repeat myself because they're
publishing this anonymously this is in
as far as political metaphors go the
perfect opportunity to use this metaphor
of lynching because what is lynching it
is an unjust mob that shows up all
anonymously nobody's held to account
nobody's following any laws and they're
taking somebody out there exacting their
vengeance
they're exacting their own poor form of
justice on that person without any
accountability that's a high-tech
lynching and fortunately we have high
tech at our disposal to go back and see
the hypocrisy of this of the very same
people like Joe Biden who were a sailing
Trump for using that word but used the
same word 20 years ago
we have that we have good high tech
there but also why is no one well we're
on the subject why is no one talking
about how offensive president Trump's
use of the term witch-hunt is to members
of the Hillary Clinton community you
ever think about that if we're really
gonna be analyzing how terms are being
so Mis applied here Trump is using
witch-hunt
as a metaphor that's very offensive to
real witches and speaking of those
witches we might get another twenty
twenty Democratic presidential candidate
a kid you not-there is a prospect right
now that we could get Hillary 3.0 this
being reported by the New York Times
being reported by a number of outlets Ms
Clint mrs. Clinton has told people
privately in recent weeks that if she
thought she could win she would consider
entering the primary but she's skeptical
that there would be an opening according
to Democrats who have spoken with her
the chances that another major contender
decides to run our remote but she's
talking about it let me tell you
something this would not appear in the
New York Times the the Clinton paper
this would not appear in the official
Democrat Pravda if this were not being
pushed by the Clinton campaign Hillary
Clinton was on a campaign stop oh my god
I was a Freudian slip she was actually
on a book stop but it seems like a
campaign stop with her daughter and she
was asked to she's gonna back in the
election she said well it's just
important we have the best candidate
it's just important that we win you know
and I'm not she's not gonna come out and
support anybody yet someone yelled from
the audience you should be the candidate
she encouraged it so get out of here oh
come on go on go on there is a chance
that we could get Hillary 3.0 and
frankly if I'm a Democrat right now
maybe that's not the worst idea you got
to give the devil her due every now and
again she did come pretty close to
beating Trump if she if she could pick
out Wisconsin on a map she very likely
would be in the White House right now
and the pitch that she was making on
that campaign stop is look you might
hate me I might be a terrible awful
corrupt person but maybe I have the best
chance to win there was that poll out of
New Hampshire from the Boston Herald it
showed that you had the top three
candidates Warren Biden and
Earnie all statistically just about tied
in New Hampshire but then when you added
in a candidate like a Michelle Obama
who's not currently in the race but it's
popular among Democrats all of a sudden
those other candidates go away Michelle
Obama's the top dog the Democrats are
unsatisfied with their choices right now
you could see Hillary 3.0 I mean I could
not possibly be more delighted if that
were the case it would be so so
enjoyable again I think we should all
encourage her as much as we can at Trump
has been encouraging her a lot it's very
possible the defining feature of the
Clintons is that they have no shame that
is the defining feature they commit
scandal after scandal with impunity they
don't answer for it and then when you
finally ask them for months and months
they say oh that's an old scandal they
just do it they lie right to your face
Bill Clinton goes on national television
lies to the American people I did not
have sexual relations with that woman
and then it goes on TV what a month or
two later is all right listen I know I
might I might I might have had sexual
relations with that woman just a little
tiny bit but I'm being really really
honest now you can believe me now Bill
Clinton with a complete straight face no
hint of irony in it whatsoever so I
can't wait I think it might actually
happen again there is a chance we can
close our eyes we can dream it would be
a lot of fun we've got a lot of
left-wing sex scandals coming up some of
them are funnier than others we will get
to the sex scandals that involve actual
elected members of Congress but there's
a bigger sex scandal at play here and
that is the sex scandal of the gender
neutral society that is the sex scandal
of trying to deny sexual difference
itself which the left has been doing for
a long time and now it's exploded in
this transgender ideology this is not
just a victimless crime this is not just
some silly social experiment we'll see
how it turns out this is affecting real
people this is very likely going to ruin
a little young boy's life we'll get into
the terrible Texas decision that that
led to that then there's a slight
victory at Lee
for sanity in this this gender ideology
movement you remember Jessica
yaniv Jessica Yaniv is that man who
identifies as a woman who put little
immigrant woman's beauty parlors out of
business these small businesses because
they refused to wax his scrotum and he
wasn't able to force himself on them you
know this is Jessica you need the same
man who tried to host a topless pool
party for LGBTQ youth 12 plus it's not a
joke this lunatic
there was a slight victory a slight
victory against him and then Miley Cyrus
could even confusing the issue further
by saying you don't need to be gay queer
icon Miley Cyrus says you don't need to
be gay if you find a good man we will
get into the specifics first I've got to
say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
you know you'll you'll probably notice
that I haven't been in my studio in LA
all week I'm now sitting in a lovely
hotel room in Gainesville Florida with
pictures of pelicans and flamingos on
the walls that is because I'm gonna be
speaking tonight at the University of
Florida when I was at the Kennesaw State
University in Georgia the other night
there was actually a professor who
required her students to protest me that
was their class assignment for the day
was to protest me obviously she had no
idea about anything I've ever said I
assume she's never heard me speak or
watched a show or listen to a lecture or
anything but she knew she hated my guts
and she wanted the students to protest
me she was a gender studies teacher
surprise surprise she taught a course
called love and sex ironic because those
are two of my favorite subjects we are
going to be taking this this tour on the
road tonight we'll be at the University
of Florida and we will be discussing a
very important uncomfortable truth
namely that leftism is not compassionate
this is how the left always tries to win
their arguments they don't win them on
the facts of the case they win it by
saying that you're a hater you're a
bigot which is such BS because it is
their ideology that is causing suffering
it is their ideology that is hateful and
dismissive of their fellow Americans and
we will we will put an end to that lie
tonight leftism is not compassionate if
you are not able to make it out to
Gainesville Florida then be sure to
check it out on
yeah YouTube page that's a young
America's Foundation YouTube page head
on over to daily wire.com ten bucks a
month hundred dollars for an annual
membership you get all the shows you get
questions in the mailbag ask them
because that's coming up tomorrow and
you get the leftist tears tumblr gonna
be very important tonight at the
University of Florida daily wire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
major setback for sanity in the gender
identity movement and this coming from a
judge in Texas Texas of all places
Jeffrey younger is a father of a
seven-year-old boy Jeffery youngers I
guess ex-wife is trying to get sole
custody of this seven-year-old boy and
is trying to transition quote unquote
the seven-year-old boy into a girl she
wants to start dressing him as a girl
making him identify as a girl and
eventually give him Huberty blockers and
permanently screw up his body chemistry
and ruin his life
Jeffery doesn't want that to happen to
his son so he petitioned a court in
Texas to give him sole custody of his
twin sons James and Jude
James younger is the little boy whose
mother is is trying to ruin his life and
James James the little boy when he's
with his mother
he says he'll he'll be called Luna and
he'll be a little girl obviously just to
please this horrible woman and but when
he's with his father he says he doesn't
want to be a girl
so the father takes this to court and
the court sides with the mother and it's
actually worth noting the the mother is
his adopted mother the mother is
actually not the biological mother of
James younger James younger was
conceived through in vitro fertilization
with Jeffery younger from Jeffrey
younger and a donor egg so the mother is
has no biological connection to the son
though she is his adopted mother and has
ostensibly helped to raise the boy who
she's now trying to turn into a little
girl or to turn into a simulacrum of a
girl the mother is an George ullis she
wants to chemically castrate her son she
wants to begin hormone replacement
therapy for her son and the court not
only did the court denied Jeffrey
youngers petition to have sole custody
it actually just granted and George
ullis sole
custody of her children and allows this
woman to go forward giving James
life-changing medical procedures based
on no science bait without any idea of
what the consequences for this will be
for this poor kid and without the
consent of his father and without his
own consent because he's a
seven-year-old boy he can't give consent
that's why we have age of consent laws I
mean the people who back this kind of
stuff is sick sick perversion just think
about age of consent because consent has
become a big topic these days especially
in the me2 movement you're telling me
that a 17 year old girl is not able to
give her consent for a one-night stand
with a 23 year old guy let's say but a 7
year old boy can give consent to
permanently alter his body chemistry
based on totally experimental medical
procedures you're telling me that a 25
year old woman a 30 year old woman who
has six or seven drinks with Matt Lauer
and then goes up to his hotel room is
too drunk to give her consent to
continue a month-long sex affair with
him but a seven-year-old boy is old
enough to give consent for life-altering
medical procedures that will permanently
screw up his body chemistry
have you lost your freaking mind know
what the left is done they're not there
they're not using their mind at all
what the left is doing here is they are
prioritizing their ideology over reality
and over human suffering as they always
do I mean this is the leftist line that
you hear as early as the French
Revolution and you hear it from people
surrounding Joseph Stalin they say you
can't make an omelet without breaking a
few eggs yeah sure maybe we're gonna
completely ruin this little boy's life
but look it's important to our gender
ideology it's important to equality of
the sexes and genders and thus it's
important to the sexual revolution that
we ruin a seven-year-old boys life so
you got to do it can't make an omelet
without breaking some eggs absolutely
terrible stuff the mother of this boy
Julis should be in prison she should be
removed from society there should be
laws to prevent this and obviously a
society that permits this kind of thing
has is not just going a little bit of
stray it has seriously rotted itself out
from the inside and it shows you just
the the work that is to be done by
anybody who has any sense of goodness
truth and beauty anybody who's trying to
conserve any semblance of sanity and
civilization in our society that's the
bad story
the good story the slight victory at
least is that that lunatic guy Jessica
Yaniv who is the one who dresses up like
a woman goes into beauty parlors and
insists that that impoverished immigrant
women wax his scrotum and when they say
no he puts them at a business that guy
the guy who was found to have
inappropriate sexual contact with
underage girls that guy the guy who this
past summer tried to host a topless LGBT
youth pool party for people ages
children ages 12 and above that guy
Jessica you need
Jessica you Nev has lost his suits
against those beauty parlors for not
waxing his genitals he lost the suits so
the Justice Center for constitutional
freedoms is representing five of the
women who were targeted by you Nev cuz
you Nev didn't just do it to one beauty
parlor he went to like a dozen beauty
parlors because he he doesn't actually
even care to get his unpleasant parts
waxed he's trying to advance this
ideology and you can't can't make an
omelet without breaking a few eggs so
he's totally willing he's eager to put
these immigrant women out of business
because it can advance his sexual
delusions and his ideological fantasies
so the Justice Center for constitutional
freedoms announced that the cases
Jessica use cases against his clients
against the the center's clients have
been thrown out by the BC Human Rights
Tribunal and Jessica Yaniv will be
forced to pay two thousand dollars to at
least three of the women that's a slight
victory okay
$2,000 is nothing in the grand scheme of
ruining someone's business you can't
live on $2,000 for very long it's a
slight victory I'm glad that a Human
Rights Tribunal in British Columbia has
not completely lost its mind it is
pretty sad by the way though that
left-wing Canada is saner on the topic
of gender ideology than a Texas
courthouse that's a big problem shows us
how far at the United States has fallen
so you Neve puts at least one of these
women out of business now he has to pay
two grand out to three women's he's got
to pay out six grand that ideology is
gonna go marching on they're not gonna
be stymied by $6,000 especially when
they're getting such victories in Texas
for those of you who say who cares it's
not a big deal let's just talk about the
economy let's forget about all this you
know gender stuff it's all wacky but
doesn't affect me how can you possibly
say that how can you stand by and say
nothing do nothing when a seven-year-old
boy's life is about to be ruined by some
sick pervert mother how can you possibly
do that based on an ideology that
changes every single day this gender and
sex ideology it's not like it's not like
we said for all of human history men are
not women and then five minutes ago we
said oh wait a minute men can be women
and we now have a fully fleshed out
ideology and this is what it is and this
is how it makes sense of course that's
not how it works
the ideology changes all the time the
sexual ideologies change all the time
at first we were told that same-sex
attraction homosexuality is a choice a
choice you're choosing certain behaviors
then we were told in the 80s and 90s
it's not a choice who would ever choose
this it is we are born this way it's the
Lady Gaga song I'm on the right track
baby I was born this way then we were
told by Cynthia Nixon a lesbian that she
chose to become a lesbian
choo choo I was a choice for her then
the transgender movement chose to adopt
this idea they said were born this way
who would ever choose to not be born
this way who would ever choose to be
born this way involved so much suffering
then we were told by the transgender
movement actually you're not born this
way you can choose your gender it's
completely fluid you can choose to be a
man one day and a woman the next day and
one of the other 54 genders the day
after that there is no internal logic
there is no consistency to these
these movements whatsoever and yet we
are told if you do not go along with
whatever we deemed to be the official
orthodoxy today we will ruin you will
put you out of business will destroy
your child's life the person who is
exemplifying this for all of us who is
actually showing the world the
incoherence of this ideology is Miley
Cyrus you know wisdom comes from strange
places sometimes Kanye West has had more
moral clarity than than most people in
the country probably over the last few
weeks Miley Cyrus is showing this to
Miley Cyrus was doing an Instagram
stream with I guess a friend of hers and
she said you don't have to be gay that
she thought she had to be gay because
she couldn't find a good man than she
found a good man and she doesn't have to
be gay anymore so you have gay icon
LGBTQ whatever icon Miley Cyrus now
coming out and saying the most
retrograde comment you possibly could
about homosexuality that it's basically
just a fallback option if you can't find
a good member of the opposite sex here's
Miley hardcourt feminist vibes and just
like I don't know not allowing anyone in
but now I am they're good men out there
guys don't give up you don't have to be
gay there are good people it's out there
you just got to find out you got to find
all the guys are evil but it's not true
there are good people out there that
just happen to have one
I've have met one time this life okay
not the most eloquent way to put it but
actually a pretty sophisticated idea
when Miley Cyrus is saying is sexuality
is very complicated sexuality is a deep
and profound and essential aspect of
human nature and we don't know
everything about it and you can't spell
it out into a little doctrine and put it
on a slogan and hand it out on a leaflet
it's very very complicated it's based on
a whole lot of factors there's even one
little factor hidden in there which is
she said I've only ever met one good guy
and he's on this stream she's ostensibly
referring to her friend how do you think
her father feels about that what do you
think that says about her relationship
with her father I don't want to get too
much into psychobabble here but she's
the one saying these things and all of
that is playing in obviously she's
saying sexuality is very complicated my
views on sexuality change a lot and of
course they do they change with seasons
of life your views on sexuality when you
are 30 years old or a lot different than
they are when you're 25 years old or a
lot different when you're 20 or a lot
different when you're 15 or a lot
different than when you're 7 years old
when this monster in Texas is trying to
castrate her adopted son that is a cause
for humility that's all I'm suggesting
that is my grand statement on
politically how to handle the sexual
revolution is slow it down you don't
know everything that you're pretending
to know we we cannot possibly comprehend
sex sex is so mysterious it's one of the
most mysterious aspects of our human
nature and if you one day declare that
this sexual innovation this new new idea
is this is the only virtuous way to view
sex you probably have it wrong maybe you
should compare that to the wisdom of the
ages because people have been thinking
about sex for a very long time Miley
Cyrus isn't the first one to do it
Jessica you Neve is not the first one to
do it this sick pervert mother in Texas
is not the first one to do it
that the court in Texas is not the first
group to do it either we've thought
about this for a long time maybe you do
not comprehend every
about one of the most complex parts of
your human nature it's the same thing by
the way on Capitol Hill this is I guess
the very literal sex scandals there are
two major sex scandals going on right
now in the House of Representatives
among Democrats that not a lot of people
are talking about because the mainstream
media are gonna block it out because it
doesn't look good for Democrats there's
Katie Hill who is a Democrat congressman
who was engaged in not just a lesbian
love affair for a couple years she was
engaged in what was termed a throuple a
three-way love affair with her husband
and this very young staffer and there's
a photo that leaked of Katie hill
sitting completely naked combing and
brushing her twenty two-year-old
staffers hair this photo leaked now
imagine of course if this were a
Republican what the story would I mean
this would be wall-to-wall coverage
demands for resignations this would be
going on 24/7 now imagine it were a man
could you oh my gosh I can't even
contemplate if it were a man but because
it's a Democrat it goes away
Ilhan omar is in a sex scandal now
because she left her husband for oh by
the way the thing with Katie Hill the
reason she broke up the couple and her
husband is now filing for divorce is
because Katie Hill simultaneously was
sleeping with her male campaign
consultant as well same thing here Ilhan
omar has an affair with her campaign
consultant she's married he's married he
leaves his wife she's leaving her
husband and they're having an affair
together I don't mention this because I
even want to publicly shame Katie hill
and Ilhan Omar for their sex scandals
politicians having sex scandals is not
news politicians having sex scandals is
a daily occurrence especially this is
true of members of Congress so I don't
mention it to shame them I mention it I
mean I'm sure they feel a lot of shame
as they should but I mention it because
one it shows you the double standard on
how sex is treated among Democrats and
Republicans two it shows you how
complicated sex and relationships are I
mean there were some people who were
applauding Katie Hill for leaving her
husband because she's come out as a
lesbian now and her husband responded
and said she's not a lesbian she's
bisexual and she's leaving me for a man
this is not don't this isn't the end so
that's a bad thing but it would be good
if she left him for a woman for some
reason and to show you the double
standard on the behavior on every topic
from sex to rhetoric to lynchings all
the way to presidential rhetoric at the
top when Democrats do it when the left
does it it's wonderful and beautiful and
to be celebrated when Republicans do
exactly the same thing it's awful and
terrible and could could never be worse
the one advantage we talked about
yesterday about how awful social media
is and how it it is really feeds into
this narcissism we all feel in our
culture the one advantage is of this
high technology is it gives us a lot of
historical perspective nothing goes away
on the internet the Internet is forever
we can compare these things we can
expose that hypocrisy that is the silver
lining and the storm cloud come check us
out tonight at the University of Florida
we're gonna be talking about why the
leftism
is it not compassionate and you can
stream that on the Yap YouTube channel
as well in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel white
house key edited by Danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by Mike or Amina hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there